[Musik]
guten abend hinein und willkommen zu
einem kurzen nachrichten update von uns
hier aus der heute redaktion
der rechtsextremismus wird immer mehr zu
einer bedrohung für die sicherheit in
deutschland so steht das im neuen
verfassungsschutzbericht der
bundesinnenminister sie zusätzlichen
auftrieb für eine gewaltbereite
rechtsextreme szene durch die korona
pandemie doch auch die gefahren die von
linksextremisten und von islamisten aus
gehen schätzt er als hoch ein
details dazu jetzt von david guetta
schulterschluss und unterwanderung
rechtsextremisten und so genannte neue
rechte hätten die korona proteste
genutzt um ihre hetzerische ideologie
ins bürgerliche spektrum zu tragen
ein schwerpunkt des heute vorgestellten
verfassungsschutzbericht
es wird deutlich dass hier eine agenda
über die reine mobilisierung zu
protesten hinausgeht und darauf abzielt
das vertrauen in staatliche
institutionen und seine repräsentanten
nachhaltig zu beschädigen extremisten
und terroristen gehen nicht in den
lockdown das personenpotenzial im
rechtsextremistischen spektrum stieg auf
33 1300 menschen knapp 40% gewaltbereit
die zahl der gewalttaten stieg um 10
prozent
die im linksextremistischen spektrum
werden nun 34 1300 personen zugeordnet
mehr als ein viertel davon gewaltbereit
die zahl der gewalttaten stieg um 34
prozent wir müssen zunehmend nicht nur
von einer besonderen gesundheitslage
reden sondern auch schon eine besondere
sicherheitslage auch die bedrohung durch
islamistischen terrorismus sei weiterhin
besorgniserregend freiheit und
demokratie insgesamt herausgefordert von
vielen seiten
die bundeswehr-eliteeinheit ksk bleibt
bestehen trotz skandalen und
rechtsradikaler vorfälle
verteidigungsministerin annegret kramp
karrenbauer sagt sie sei überzeugt dass
ein positiver wandel eingesetzt habe
wegen der einzigartigen militärischen
fähigkeiten brauche man das ksk neuer
kommandeur der reformierten truppe wird
der afghanistan general ansgar meyer und
jetzt in der sendung die aktuellen
corona zahlen in deutschland die weiter
zurückgehen das robert koch institut
meldet 652 neuinfektionen binnen eines
tages das sind 552 weniger als
vergangenen dienstag 93 todesfälle kamen
dazu die sieben tage incidents sinkt auf
jetzt 15,5 ein lange gern dass streit
zwischen europa und den usa ist vorerst
entschärft es geht um subventionen für
die flugzeughersteller airbus und boeing
die gegenseitigen strafzölle werden für
fünf jahre ausgesetzt das ist ein
ergebnis des besuchs von us präsident
joe biden bei der eu in brüssel
der klimawandel bedroht auch die
kühlkammern der erde die polarregionen
das ist das ergebnis einer
forschungsreise die es so noch nie
gegeben hat
ein jahr lang hat das deutsche
forschungsschiff polarstern in der
arktis daten gesammelt
ein ergebnis das heute vorgestellt wurde
meeresströmungen aus dem atlantik werden
immer wärmer und sorgen dafür dass sich
im winter weniger eis bildet als früher
mehr dazu von kai niklasch
der lebensraum der eisbären schrumpft
weiterhin dramatisch ein grund dafür
warme wassermassen aus dem nordatlantik
strömen in die hand mehrere des
arktischen ozeans und beschleunigen den
eisverlust insgesamt habe sich das eis
der arktis während der expedition
schneller zurückgezogen als jemals zuvor
wir haben dabei mit unseren eigenen
augen gesehen diesem besteht ist das
ganzjährige eis der arktis überhaupt
noch zu retten
wenn man das marode und völlig zum
nordpol im sommer 2020 gesehen haben
irgendwann tatsächlich manchmal zweifel
über kommen forscher aus 20 nationen
worten tief ins eis kerne zu entnehmen
schickten sonnen ins meer und diesen
wetterballons aufsteigen
wissenschaftliche prognosen sagen voraus
dass die artis bereits im sommer 2035
und nicht erst 2050 eisfrei sein könnte
und dann gibt es heute abend natürlich
dass die em geht so richtig los für
deutschland
joachim löws team muss ran gegen
weltmeister frankreich das hier nennt
man wohl demonstrative gelassenheit
mannschaft spaziergang im englischen
garten in münchen heute mittag diese
damen und herren in blau hier sind
allerdings sicher dass das kein
spaziergang werden wird für die
deutschen gute stimmung in münchen
anstoß in zwei stunden
das wetter passt mit viel sonne in der
mitte auch mal wolken dazu
höchsttemperaturen zwischen 26 und 34
grad und damit sagen wir danke für ihr
interesse und wünschen einen sehr
angenehmen fußballabend hier im zdf